hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to huniepop now I took
a little bit of a breather so that I can
get some energy back up so that I'll be
able to flirt with all these girls even
better than before but what I have right
now is Tiffany is at two hearts Keanu is
at four hearts cube Ellie they're done
Celeste in mo more at four hearts and I
believe Jessie and Nikki are both at one
I don't think I've got a single date
with them so I'm gonna go to Turtle Bay
Beach with Tiffany go on a few dates and
then round out the crew it just seems so
weird I'm just crossing them off my lip
like check done bank check done bank
check done banked there's nothing about
it I need some emotional attachment in
my life message from Kiana master
whatever you need I'm here for you I'm
just happy to be able to spend time with
you
Oh again really weird really weird I
don't like that but anyway let's go on a
date with what's-her-face here actually
let me make sure that I got all the
things that she needs and some special
stuff gravity boobity boom I am serious
I'm very serious hmm how old are you I
don't know 21 sorry I don't remember
anything go on a date come on we got no
time we got a lot of girls to get
through nothing you need to know that
but I need to just inform you that I'm
seeing a lot of girls aliens cats tons
of girls all over the place okay fine
uh-huh yeah tell me more about how
amazing I am I know I know I'm the best
at whatever the hell is going on I'm not
even paying attention
Hey holy crap that didn't do as much as
I thought it was gonna but it was very
impressive all that happened which is
kind of the story of my life in every
girl that I've ever met
Oh failure no oh oh I wasn't even paying
attention oh no oh that was my first
failure of this session I failed many
before but this is my first one how it
hurts my heart
I've been crushed why would Tiffany
reject me I'm perfect in every way how
crazy possible does not she knows that I
am the greatest ever oh I'll go with
Jesse and Jesse will be happy to see me
and then you can go screw yourself cuz
I'm not gonna I'm so lonely hello Jesse
I'd miss you yeah I miss you too
I've got tons of money I guess I need to
do something with you here take some of
my money is that gonna buy you Mia love
I heard you like drinking at all hours
of the day it's a gym why would a gym
need bottle service you have a problem
alright let's try going on a date with
Jesse I'm sure this is gonna go much
better than the date with her daughter
oh that just reminds me the ones that I
haven't talked to Helen oh hell you do
Ben welcome to the Springs
I don't know about that but I mean you
deserve plenty I guess maybe I don't
know
damn oh this better be enough oh yes god
damn it uh I made it with the mom but
not the daughter I made it with the mom
oh that makes me feel good about my life
choices yeah I should treat you and
pamper you and shower you with gifts is
that what you're saying is that what I
should go so what I could do okay good I
need to suck some honey out of you
giving me as much honey as you possibly
can
no Kuni who drop out of high school to
care for my daughter I know your
daughter I tried to date her and yet she
didn't accept me what can you do I would
so like I don't care I think that's all
I got out of her
okay I've sucked as much Funi as I could
out of Jessie so now I need to go and
meet with ooh Who am I gonna meet with
Who am I gonna take home tonight
Momo Celeste or Kiana
hmm between a cat and alien and a mom oh
the choices I have to make between a cat
alien and a mom I'll take the mom thank
you bye guys bye bye Jessie bye bye I'm
gonna go uh take another Lydia for a
night and once I'm not gonna be able to
do this one either I just got to get my
combos better oh I love my boobs in this
pic of all the pics out there than on
the internet this is my favorite oh good
I'm so glad you love your boobs
you have a very Audrey esque feel about
you boy hi how's it goin oh my god
all right let's see you see here I
suppose I could get you drugged up
blarp blarp blarp was it pretty strong I
don't know about that hey I need I need
to suck the honey out before I get into
this so I gotta get as much honey as
possible and then I'm gonna be able to
do this oh look at all that honey I
don't know them Hey Wow okay I didn't
know what I was trying to say I'm just
trying to give you presents I know I
should have given you that first how do
you feel about kids kids let's see I
love kids they bring so much joy into
your life most guys can't handle that I
have a baby oh well they're stupid I'm
smart sleep with me all right let's go
come on daytime I got an empty bed and
I'm creepy okay goodbye
get ready Oh what am I ever gonna be
normal
what am I ever gonna be able to be
normal around a woman I mean in real
life no in real life I'm not normal
around women either yeah oh yes I don't
need to do anything with hop right into
bed didn't shall we
oh no okay let's do this bang nice oh so
nice oh so nice that's me baby I'm nice
mr. class hmm what are you wait for
there we go hey I'm gonna get the sex
how many to the Mexico's we're gonna
bang sex Eagles yeah everyone else in
the house cause things are really really
nice I hope my neighbors can't hear me
because this is gonna be very bizarre
for them to understand I'm gonna bang
slightly cold yeah okay anyway hello sue
well since you're hearing your anyway I
thought we'd play some Jenga shut up I
am in the middle of something do not
update I swear to God I will punch you
he's younger no gears [ __ ] ogres oh
my gosh oh my gosh curse oh gosh - gosh
whose liberty beauty huh yes give me the
sexy of me the sex oh yes I just she's
all over the bed oh yeah that's how you
do it ladies and gentlemen
that's how whoa hey how are you doing
well then do bad you guys can't see this
because this is titillating to say the
least definitely have to do that again
well we're not gonna excuse me I have to
mop up all my sweat that got really hot
and heavy if you know what I mean
this time things are gonna go
differently between me and the tipster
tiffany is gonna be very happy when I
tell her all about my interest with her
mother and she's going to be very
interested in how that went about so I'm
just gonna talk about nothing but that
the entire time nothing's happening shut
up
laptop Pro man what kind of sugar daddy
him I just bought her laptop good god
you did probably didn't have this
already
I can't believe you got this for me
thanks we'd either okay let's go on a
date this time it's gonna go good yeah
I'm ready to go I think I might fail
again but I know I didn't even look at
your good interests Jeremy why didn't I
look at your interests fishing at the
church player in my tears
what about Lola Lola is a pretty good
cheer tennis player I've heard not that
I know are very intimately also I know
your mom god damn it
[ __ ] just let me use it
jeezum z-- what the hell oh my god you
gotta be kidding me you have to be
kidding me I have them the right there
oh man
this is so stupid it's right there [ __ ]
there we go god damn it it was so stupid
I had two of them right there and right
there
and I couldn't use them because the
combo never came up so stupid so stupid
even though I won it's fine whatever
good now time to go hang out with your
mom all right Oh in little saucy here
getting a little saucy getting a little
saucy was a little unorthodox for me but
that's not my fault it's not my fault
what are you like mama you like
sexuality and not romance well I've got
oodles of that shooting out of my boo
boo I don't know what my boo boo is shut
up don't ask me don't ask me what my boo
boo is don't ask me what my boo boo is I
really don't know what my boo boo is
shut up shut up shut up I don't know
what my boo boo is all right let's get
you drunk let's get you nice and drunk
did I have a punching bag if I had a
punching bag I love it when you buy me
new did I just buy your punching bag
they don't really recall that what's
your favorite drink favorite drink
Martin Dini she likes a martini well I
got tons of martinis ready for you baby
also I've got lots of really hard liquor
to get you super drunk I know I know I
am let's go on date by the way I want to
bang your daughter nice oh hang on a
second in the middle of this date I have
a text message so shut your face hey I
took this for you your pervert it's from
your daughter boy I wonder what it is oh
hey mama
look at your daughter that's really
weird I'm sorry about this is more
creepy than I thought I thought it was
gonna be funny it wasn't funny that was
really weird
I'm gonna pay your daughter oh look at
me look at me are you looking at me are
you looking at me lady are you looking
at me are you looking at how great I am
because I'm pretty great are you looking
at me okay thanks thank you thank you
thank you so much I do have a lot of
experience with virtual women and
nothing else
ah okay
it's nighttime Who am I gonna go for am
I going to go for the alien or the cat
the alien or the cat VA of a cat
I don't know God why did I make that
choice I just want to get it out of the
way I want to get this horrible horrible
experience out of the way so that I can
move on to greener pastures and be happy
with my life even though that's probably
not gonna happen oh good we're already
on our bedroom
great I have a text from Jesse I was so
excited I got signed to do a Sullivan
for a pretty popular site they saw my
banana set and had to have me oh oh your
banana set what are you doing with that
banana
Jihan of potassium okay bye-bye
I'm gonna go sleep with the cat why
David like dad all right let's get this
horror horror show over with fourth day
with no mo little boy mm-hmm shut up
just shut up shut up I have to I have I
have to do this oh so close
huh I'm always cutting it down to the
wire and I don't know why yes oh boy I
get now I remembered my reward I get to
see you can't make me in this game mmm I
think I know what to do I saw pictures
in those books you have under your bed
okay right now I'm not here right now on
oh god oh god the picture ah no no no no
no aah yeah yeah yeah well I feel dirty
I feel really really really dirty anyway
thank you everybody so much for watching
sorry to put you through that I'm not
gonna be okay but thanks again and
[ __ ] it's uh we'll see you in the
next video bye bye